each year science magazines editors and
new staff select a breakthrough of the
year
a novel finding that makes headway in
solving a long-standing problem and is
of interest to a wide array of people in
this video a few of our news writers
provide a brief glimpse of both the 2011
breakthrough and the 9 runners-up this
last year marks a turning point in HIV
prevention AIDS surface 31 years ago and
in the intervening years there have been
very few prevention efforts that use a
biomedical intervention that have proven
themselves to work so we've relied on
things like condoms and behavior change
and we know the limitations of those now
it's been shown if you treat somebody
with antiretroviral drugs you lower
their risk of transmitting to someone by
96% combining that with other biomedical
prevention interventions that have
proven themselves as well as the
behavioral in condoms has led to a
concept now that we can actually end the
epidemic in locales if not the entire
world in time this is not a vaccine a
vaccine would be a there's a great
desire to have something that you give
somebody three times and they're
protected for life this requires
treatment for decades on end it's
complicated it's costly but it's
something that the world can do tomorrow
and that has changed the level of hope
in a way that's profound
for decades astronomers have been
confused about where the most common
types of meteorites that follow the
earth come from they come from the
asteroid belt but when they looked out
into the asteroid belt
the most common asteroids they saw
didn't look like the meteorites they had
in their hands in 2011 Japanese
scientists were able to analyze tiny
bits of the asteroid Itokawa that the
Hayabusa spacecraft had returned to
Earth and with a close look they could
see that the asteroid has the same
chemical and mineralogical composition
as the most common meteorites found on
earth so that told them that the
distinctive reddened color of the
asteroids was just an overlay it had
been fooling them but it wasn't easy the
return of the Hayabusa spacecraft was
complicated by mechanical failures
need to fall back on one backup after
another but this year the decades-old
conundrum of where the most common
meteorites come from has been resolved
last year a flurry of new studies came
out that showed as modern humans the
first members of Homo sapiens came out
of Africa sometime in the last hundred
thousand years they encountered archaic
people in more than one place and in a
bread with them and so a whole group of
new studies came out that tried to find
who still carries the DNA from these
encounters of the prehistoric kind they
found DNA in Europeans and Asian's that
show that they interbred the modern
humans interbred with Neanderthals but
they also found that Melanesians
Australian Aborigines and Negrete owes
and the Philippines carried DNA from a
new kind of human that was discovered in
Siberia that lived more than thirty
thousand years ago
so it's very interesting we carry a
small amount of DNA between say
- and 10% of our DNA from archaic people
that we interact with on at least three
different continents this is significant
because it's changing our models of
modern human origins it turns out that
as Homo sapiens came out of Africa they
didn't completely replace the akai
archaic people we still carry some of
their DNA in our veins
this year researchers in Japan gave us
our first full-scale atomic look at a
protein complex called photosystem ii so
photosystem ii is the protein that
plants used to split water into hydrogen
and oxygen and chemists would very much
like to do the same thing to generate
molecular hydrogen that can be used as
an alternative fuel that wouldn't have
any co2 or other carbon compounds that
would be greenhouse gases and so what's
amazing about the catalyst that is that
the core of photosystem ii is it is
virtually unchanged by billions of years
of evolution which tells it tells us
that it is exquisitely tuned to doing
its job and chemists are now trying to
learn those exact same lessons to be
able to use those insights for
alternative energy so a better
understanding of how plants do this
which the structure does provide could
really help that effort so this year
astronomers found something very unusual
they found two clouds of gas twelve
billion light-years away that are made
almost entirely of hydrogen they have no
elements in them that are heavier which
is very surprising because two billion
years after the Big Bang which is the
era when these two gas clouds existed
the universe was supposed to have been a
very violent place and all of the gases
in the universe were supposed to have
been mixed up amongst themselves so that
no pockets of the universe were supposed
to be left uncontaminated by heavier
elements made in the hearts of stars the
other find along the same lines with the
discovery of a star
that again seems to be made entirely of
hydrogen and helium and has no elements
heavier than those together these finds
suggests that the chemical evolution of
the universe had more twists and turns
than astronomers had taught the
microbiome is the community of organisms
that live in and on our bodies in over
the last few years we've really come to
appreciate how diverse those communities
are so we decided that microbiome
research deserved runner-up status
because there were several key papers
that came out in 2011 one has to do with
discerning a pattern in the complexity
of the gut bacteria we now think we can
divide these communities into three
categories these categories correlate
with long-term diet and are named
according to the dominant bacteria in
them we also advanced our understanding
of the role of microbiome in cancer in
immune system function and in metabolic
diseases and together all this work
really enhanced our appreciation of just
how important these microbial
communities are to our health and
well-being
so 2011 saw the publication of the first
partial results of a phase 3 clinical
trial of a malaria vaccine this was a
huge study involving more than 15,000
young children in seven countries in
Africa all the way from Ghana to
Mozambique now malaria vaccine
development has been an incredibly
frustrating difficult field with lots of
disappointments and this was the first
phase free study with some real degree
of success
about half of the children aged between
5 and 17 months were protected from
severe malaria which can be fatal if you
get it that's still not a terrific
result most vaccines perform much better
than that and there are other questions
about this vaccine as well we don't know
how long the protection will last if it
wanes after one or two years we also
don't know how much this vaccine will
costs but it will be affordable for the
countries that really need it or who
will pay the bills but still given given
the long and frustrating history it's a
start and researchers can build on this
vaccine to design maybe others that that
do better so despite all the
shortcomings we think this is a
runner-up for breakthrough of the year
so for the past 15 years astronomers
have been discovering all sorts of
exoplanets or planets outside the solar
system these are strange beasts some are
as dense as lead some as light as
styrofoam and this year they've
continued to discover several weird
exoplanets as well as weird exoplanetary
systems in February they discovered a
system with six planets five of which
are closer to their parent star than
mercury is to the Sun that is very
surprising because you don't expect so
many planets to be bunched up together
so close to the parent star on the other
extreme astronomers discovered a cluster
of free-floating planets that
appeared to have come unhinged from
their parent star in fact there was no
parent star in sight
and so these discoveries are showing
that planetary systems have a chaotic
history of violent history that
researchers are only now beginning to
understand
so zeolites are a family of porous
minerals that we've known about for over
250 years and they've extremely useful
in modern society we use them as
catalysts as for breaking apart things
like the long hydrocarbon chains in oil
into the shorter ones that are in
gasoline that are more volatile they are
used to as filters for purifying air
purifying water now the problem was the
eliza's that in the past they've tended
to have extremely small pores and that's
limited their usefulness what happened
this year was that researchers in Korea
and then another group in France in
Germany came up with way different ways
to make zeolites without only the small
pore sizes but also larger ones which
could make them as useful catalysts for
and filters for a wider variety of
compounds researchers in Minnesota also
reported a new way to make ultra-thin
zeolite membranes which could be very
useful as cheaper more effective filters
and catalysts as well so I think about
2011 taught us is that zeolite research
still has a lot of potential head
scientists studying cells in the
laboratory have known for a long time
that those cells will slowly stop
dividing and enter a period of old age
or what they call senescence they've
also learned more recently that
senescence cells build up in certain
tissues and may contribute to
age-related symptoms such as cataracts
the wrinkling of skin even the muscle
weakness that comes to many elderly but
they haven't been able to prove that the
senescence cells caused those symptoms
this year at the Mayo Clinic in
Minnesota a team actually showed that
for the first
they genetically engineered mice so that
if given a drug their senescence cells
would be eliminated those mice didn't
live longer but they did have a
healthier life they warded off some of
those age-related symptoms if the drug
was given to middle-aged mice they also
benefited not clear that we can target
senescence cells and people but if we
can figure out a way we might be able to
live healthier if not longer